last year
when
the rams and the chiefs play a game that
finishes 54-51
oh it's set defenses back a hundred
years
yesterday's game was 48-46 and i haven't
heard anybody complain yeah that that it
sets defense back or i mean if i'm a fan
of either the 49ers or the saints i'm
troubled today
even if i'm a 49ers fan my defense gave
up 46 freaking points that's not good no
you're right and it's funny that you
know there isn't that complaint and even
for me i don't feel like there's a
complaint i guess a little bit what's
different about these two teams compared
to the chiefs and rams is just a little
more dedication to the run game in
general uh but either way that was a
back and forth game i don't love those
type of football games as exciting as
that was i don't love it even though
that was great to watch yesterday i'm
not going to deny that uh what don't you
like about it um what at what point is
it too much scoring i i once you get
past like the mid 30s i feel like it
goes a little crazy but like i could
appreciate it yesterday this is what's
different about the rams and the chiefs
so much of it was unbelievable play
design by the other by the other two
last year i felt like guys were just
running straight in the rams chief
scanner like whoa they're open it was
like that more bad defense i guess
yesterday i saw more genius play calling
and scheming by peyton and shanahan that
made the game like holy cow look at the
design of that play wow that was
unbelievable uh so i think that's the
big thing and for me the big thing of
that game in general if i just had to
hit one headline it would be jimmy g you
know again it's not that it's not that
uh he played great in a big moment
that's what i'm saying he did he played
great in a big moment and i know some of
the completions were easy to beat
because shanahan is designing it exactly
right not the first quarterback in the
history to have a good but but don't we
want to see garoppolo
in a spot where the play that was drawn
up didn't work the way it was supposed
to mean like this one and the touchdown
he's about to blanketed oh no this is
the scramble okay this is the this is
the penalty yeah oh but but i want to
see almost like the catch i mean it kind
of started to look like it did you know
nothing's there you roll out and you
make something out of nothing all right
let's see we're watching it here on
nbcsn for the issue on the radar
the throw with the game on the line the
george kittle play and and you had a
great uh instagram breakdown of it
yesterday and peter king tells the story
of how you know the the 49ers called a
timeout kyle shanahan didn't like the
formation didn't like the play he
thought i could come up with something
better right so at the very last second
just as jimmy garoppolo is getting ready
to call the snap and the play clock's
about to go to zero
they call the timeout they change the
play and they come up with this bunch
formation on the left and springs kittle
open and then he does the george the
animal steel routine down the sideline
he's getting face masks and he drives
the guy 20 yards he ends up on the
14-yard line just amazing what a play
and let me let me say this yeah say it
it's all right the contrast between
fourth and two in that spot right and
what kyle shanahan came up with and
fourth and three last monday night and
what the vikings came up with for kirk
customs exactly right what a difference
right what a difference right that play
right there had a lot of answers okay
even if if they decide to a double uh a
george kittle in that scenario there's
still two or three other places that
okay they've doubled kittle hey jimmy
garoppolo i've taught you through our
week to go to this and this now off of
that and that's where it's different
than your vikings play that we talked
about last week against the seahawks to
win the game but uh you put cousins in
that spot he makes that throw no doubt
about it
you're right i mean i'm not gonna sit
here and go oh my gosh what a special
throw by jimmy garoppolo but nonetheless
he got it done fourth and two throws a
good accurate ball to where kittle can
turn it up the sideline and make
something of it and it just goes back to
the genius of kyle shanahan with his
play call and play design he just got so
many wrinkles formations you know
pre-snap motions and shifts to throw
your defense's head and all over the
place where's it going uh and sean
payton too it's it's no different over
there but kyle's maybe a little more
crazy behind the line of scrimmage but i
just think that our one of our big
questions was can jimmy garoppolo
really come through in those type of
moments when the run game isn't just
absolutely dominating the run game was
really good don't get me wrong but i
still think it's a good stepping stone
for him the team the fan base to all say
oh this is our guy he can take us to the
promised land when when we need him too
his stats were almost identical i
identical to uh drew brees they both had
349 yards passing garoppolo had four
touchdown passes breeze had five and
breeze had an up and over the top
touchdown at the goal line 29 of 40 was
breezed 26 35 was garoppolo they both
played really really well yes they both
did it was just one of those games where
somebody had to lose yeah and uh you
know it's nothing to be ashamed of if
you lose that game but what a difference
though saints go from one seed right to
three seed and the 49ers rock it from
five to one when you couple it with the
seahawks loss on sunday night football
and the 49ers are right where they want
to be now you know and and again even
though the 49ers have beaten the saints
in new orleans and the saints have
beaten the seahawks in seattle and the
seahawks have beaten the 49ers in san
francisco
kind of you know killing that whole home
field advantage
notion you still want to have home field
advantage in the playoffs you want to
have the week off yeah you want people
to come to you the the big thing is the
bye week no doubt about it because you
know it just gives your team a chance to
get back to a hundred percent and allows
you to put the pedal to the metal just
that much harder when it becomes
divisional playoff time and the san
francisco 49ers are a team especially
where i look at to where that could be
important for them this year because
they had the early bye week right they
had the week four bye week this year if
i'm i missed you know yes i'm not
mistaken somewhere around there uh so
that will be a much needed rest for them
especially you know as it looks week 17
they're going to come you know have that
huge matchup with uh the seattle
seahawks up in seattle but still uh that
was a fun game two really good football
teams shocking that they let up that
many points i mean these are two of the
better defenses in football but i think
it was the first time all year they
faced offenses that really
had scheme good player good offensive
line and kind of took the fight to the
defense for the first time all year
where hey i got to give drew brees a lot
of credit too you know one of the things
i complain about with him and the saints
is a little bit of a lack of you know
plus 10 plus 15 plus 20 yard throws in a
football game he did that especially
early on which i think backed off san
francisco a little bit and and took
their aggression away to go oh okay we
can't crowd the line of scrimmage with
drew today he's kind of pushing the ball
down the field and it might not be
rockets but it's effective and uh that
certainly helped out their offense early
on there are so many good teams in the
nfc this year yeah it's a shame that you
know a team like the saints having a
special season they may end up playing
wild card weekend the way things are
going a team like the vikings that are
nine and four they could be 12 and four
and be the sixth seed it's just amazing
to see how that's all playing out of
course one of the problems is you have
one of the worst divisions we've ever
seen and they're guaranteed to put a
team in a spot where they didn't have a
home playoff game but uh that there's
your nfc east break down there it stinks
top to bottom the rest of the nfc pretty
good though and you know it's going to
come down to week 17 49ers seahawks the
winner is going to most likely be the 1c
the loser is going to be the five seed
the playoffs are going to be more
interesting in the nfc if the 49ers are
the five seed because the 49ers are the
one seed yeah it's i
yeah they win both games at home and
they go to the super bowl they're the
five seed they're gonna have to you know
go on the road and it's gonna i think
the games are gonna be better so so what
you're saying is 49 49ers are clearly
the better team in the nfc i think that
if they would have the one seed they're
more likely to win the two games at home
in advance yeah now now um i mean i'm
with you there too but but you know the
good thing is for a team like the saints
right
you're on the road if you do get you
know whatever you get the 2 seat or 3c
whatever it may be and you have to play
san francisco in the nfc championship
game it's not a horrible environment for
a team and a quarterback who's don't
always have a great reputation for
playing outdoor games in the playoffs
and bad elements it won't be bad
elements in san francisco that time of
the year it won't be that bad so i could
i do think that if we saw these two
teams play each other again again
we could see
you know another that type of
performance 35 31 something like that
from both of them where it'd be a lot of
fun and who knows who comes out on top
and remember they had that epic game
between the four that's what i was kind
of thinking the saints that was a
candlestick right in 2011. right but
there's gonna be you know divisional
round right wild card round is always
exciting but the one thing that always
nags me during wild card weekend is the
notion that all four of these winners
may be done by next weekend but the
divisional round it they're just and
it's going to be more special like it's
the best eight it's going to be more
special this year than i think it's been
in a long time yeah well i think the the
all all four
you know number one seeds you know are
number one and number two sees all four
first round by teams i think we're all
going to look at it and go oh they're
very deserving of being there they
clearly are you know one of the four
best teams in football and ooh you know
might it might be you know a little bit
close with the seahawks if they're just
outside of it or the packers to where we
go oh well now the wild card game we're
going to have i mean the divisional game
we're going to have something special
there yeah but what's beautiful about it
is we still don't know who those teams
no that are going to be no idea i mean
hey the packers i mean they could lose
to the bears this week let's be serious
i mean what is what are the packers done
lately and you know everybody out there
knows i love aaron rodgers come on but i
mean what have they done lately to give
you confidence to go wow green bay is
really they're really something special
you know they if you're special
you don't let washington hang on no
doubt about it they did yes who the heck
did they let him uh hang around last
week oh the giants it was 17 13 in the
fourth quarter you know again so i'm not
going to sit here yet and go oh yeah
green bay is definitely in the cream of
the crop they're finding ways to win
they have a schedule that's kind of
favorable to them and they have a
quarterback who knows how to mess a game
up and make a big play when it does
count
so the
saints 49ers game
included a controversial non-call of
pass interference but this time it was
appropriate terror is more tweeted i
don't make the rules i just play by them
he's the guy who committed blatant pass
interference it can't be passed
interference because on a fake punt
there is no pass interference because
there's too much contact down the field
that it would be a cheap and easy way to
throw a ball up and get a pass
interference call when the gunner
doesn't know the ball is coming and i'm
not sure memory even had any idea the
ball was coming oh so i wonder if he
even knew the rule really yeah now more
uh may have held and sean payton was
arguing vociferously for a holding foul
but
none of it was to be and that was that
but uh yeah superdome
pass interference
non-call
anytime that ever happens right as long
as that building is standing it's going
to be a big deal and it was a big deal
yesterday and the fans didn't want to
hear it they explained it on the pa
system and the fans still booed they
didn't they refused to accept it first
off that's like not holding on the punt
play so that's why they can't go back
and do that if you did every play is
holding the whole gear and the punt
right i mean
if you're inside the shoulders like that
they don't call that holding in the nfl
so that's why they're not going to get
that call either just a weird part of
the game fourth and 18 first of all to
do that right i know it makes me wonder
a little if the saints were aware of
this rule either uh but that was huge
because the 49ers were up and then they
went on a 14-play 55-yard drive from
there and scored a touchdown to go up by
12 at that point uh which really put the
saints in a tough spot they had to know
if the special team's question i hope
doesn't know there's no past
interference on a fake punch i hope
she'll be fired right now i hope so but
you would have fourth and 18 just
throwing a go round at that point of the
game i don't know
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports